hey everyone in cereth register nurse re
and calm and today i'm going to
demonstrate how to find the 9 most
common pulse points as the nurse it's
important to know these common pulse
sites because some of them you will be
using routinely during your assessments
now the ones that you're not using
routinely it's still really important to
know where they are located and whenever
you're assessing the pulse you will be
looking at a few things one thing will
be the rate how fast is it along with
the strength and you'll be grading it on
a scale zero to three with zero being
absent one plus it's week two plus it's
normal and three plus its bounding and
then you'll want to look at the rhythm
is it regular or irregular and as you
fill on the pulse some of the sites you
will be filling bilaterally to see if
they're equal the only one you really
don't feel on at the same time is the
carotid we will be filling on that one
at a time
now the nine pulse points we will be
assessing in this video will be the
timbrel the carotid apical brachial
radial femoral popliteal posterior
tibial and dorsalis pedis to find the
pulse points we're going to start from
her head and work our way down it just
makes it easier going in that order and
to find the pulse points you can use
your first two or first three fingers
and we're going to find the temporal
artery and to find this artery you'll
want to find landmarks and this always
goes for any pulse point that you're
trying to find now this temporal artery
comes off of the external carotid and
goes up and what you want to do is you
want to find the tragus of the ear which
is this part of the ear and the
zygomatic arch is found above it which
is a fancy way of saying the cheekbone
so your pulse site where this X is is
found right here this is your temporal
artery and you'll want to feel
bilaterally and see if they are equal
and the time that a nurse really feels
on this is during that head-to-toe
assessment when whenever we're assessing
the pulses in the head the next pulse
point we're going to assess is the
carotid artery and it is
found in the neck and this artery is
most commonly assessed during CPR in an
adult and it supplies our brain and our
head with blood now whenever you are
assessing the carotid artery as I
pointed out at the beginning of the
video you will assess each side at a
time you will not do it bilaterally
because we don't want to stimulate the
vagus nerve which can drop the heart
rate and decrease circulation to the
brain to find this pulse point we'll use
the landmarks of the jaw because we're
gonna go below the jaw we're gonna have
the patient tilt the head like this and
we're gonna find the trachea and the
sternocleidomastoid ahead to toe
assessment or before the administration
of digoxin and in an adult we want to
make sure we listen to the apical pulse
with our stethoscope for one full minute
and to hold the medication if apical
pulse is less than 60 beats per minute
and this side is the point of maximal
impulse and is located at the apex of
the heart so it's going to be on the
left side of the chest at the fifth
intercostal space midclavicular lee so
what you want to do it's best if you
have your patient lie on their back and
you'll need your stethoscope by the way
because you want to actually listen to
the pulse and count it so how you do
that you want to find your landmarks so
you want to find your sternal notch
which is this notch up here then go down
the angle of Luis and you're gonna go to
the second intercostal space
midclavicular so this is about mid
clavicular we're gonna go to the second
intercostal space which is about right
here now we got to get to the fifth
intercostal space because this is where
our pulse is so we're gonna go three
four five so our pulse is located here
in this area then we're going to take
our stethoscope and we will listen and
assess the pulse now it's fine
PulsePoint in the arm which is the
brachial artery and this is a major
artery found in the upper arm and it
will actually go and divide into the
radial and the ulnar artery now we use
this pulse point for whenever were
assessing the blood pressure and during
CPR in an infant we will check this site
and how you want to check the size you
want to have the patient extend their
arm and turn their arm out where their
palms are facing upward to find this
artery you want to find the area of the
cubital fossa which is this triangular
area in front of the elbow and the
brachial artery is found near the top of
this cubital artery in this location
right here next we're going to find the
radial pulse point and this artery
branches off from the brachial artery
and helps provide circulation to our arm
and hand and we most commonly use this
pulse point for measuring a pulse rate
in an adult and to find that how you're
going to do that is just extend the arm
out and make sure the palms are facing
upward just like how you did with the
brachial artery this artery is found
right below the thumb within the wrist
area along the radial bone and you will
suss it in this area right here next
we're going to find the femoral pulse
point and this is a major artery in the
groin that provides circulation to the
legs and to fill this artery you have to
palpate deeply in the groin area and it
is found below the inguinal ligament and
between the pubic symphysis and the
anterior superior iliac spine next we're
going to find the popliteal pulse site
and this comes off the femoral artery
and it's located behind the knee in
these areas right here to find this
pulse point you're going to flex the
knee and you're gonna take both your
hands put them behind the knee and you
will find it at about the middle area of
the popliteal fossa which is a diamond
shape pitted area behind the knee and
this artery is pretty deep so helping to
the knee will help you find that artery
now we're going to find the posterior
tibial and the dorsalis pedis and these
sides are assessed during your
head-to-toe assessment especially if
your patient might have peripheral
vascular disease or if they've had a
vascular procedure like a heart cath
where they access the femoral artery
we'll always be checking the pulses in
these lower extremities
now the dorsalis pedis want to turn the
fit a little bit this way is found here
and in order to find that what you can
do is find the e HL tendon the extensor
helices longus tendon that actually
helps extend this big toe so if you've
lift your toe it for me you can see that
tendon dry in here now just follow that
tendon and then just go a little bit to
the end of it and that will be your
dorsalis pedis then we'll find the
posterior tibial and this is found on
the inside of the ankle found between
the back of the medial malleolus which
is the bony prominence of the ankle bone
and Achilles tendon so you'll find it
within this area right here okay so that
wraps up this video over the nine most
common pulse points and remember
whenever you are counting the pulse rate
if it's regular you will count it for 30
seconds and multiply it by two if it's
irregular you will count it for one full
minute and we always count the apical
pulse for one full minute thank you so
much for watching and don't forget to
subscribe to our channel for more videos